ready okay a few years ago we snuck into
one of the world's most exclusive
celebrity parties and this is that story
hi guys I'm and I'm good
yeah I remember sitting in my dorm room
I think I was on my laptop or something
I was like reading about the mecca I
don't think oh I want to go like I wish
I was like famous or knew somebody I was
like okay she should go to this and I'm
I give you good psychic quick sidenote
the Met Gala is an event put on by the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and okay I
believe all the coolest hottest celebs
come and dressed to the nines and
there's always like a really sick theme
so as soon as I said this to you you
were like yeah let's do it and neither
one of us were really like are you sure
or like yeah that was no resistance no
we happened and we just started playing
yeah initially we thought our best bet
would have been to be waitresses I feel
like we got that idea from a movie or
some reason that was like our go-to but
then it just seemed grab the time yeah
but then I kind of we realized it
wouldn't really work we didn't know if
they will watch us back shirts ties we
just did a massive brainstorm of all out
option so we thought of Marazzi
we're gonna be celeb stylists we found
out that this major magazine was gonna
be there and we thought that maybe we
could be a part of it I remember you
said thing we liked people's LinkedIn
pages and being like we're gonna be this
person this is our job like this is our
title this is what we do we ended up
deciding against using other people's
names because like that's wack and weird
so we were just gonna we went as
ourselves but we had like titles and we
were a part of this publication you
pointed out that a lot of the
photographers and press people were
wearing like just black black and white
so I think that's we were just like
we're gonna blend in I remember I went
to a thrift store and I was like sending
you photos of the dresses I was trying
on and then I just found this one it was
amazing it was a black long dress a
little bit revealing at the front just a
little just a little I ended up wearing
I wanted to look professional so I ended
up wearing
a laser with nothing underneath some
gold jewelry fashion Oh black pants keep
in mind all of this is happening like 48
hours in advance of the actual mikela I
guess it was hard to actually find the
information of where to go right they
are good at keeping it under wraps
I had class that day yeah and you had
mentioned that we should get there a bit
earlier because we were pressed we
picked a time to go that like works for
both of us and I feel like we're rushing
to get ready it was like oh my god this
is happening through a lot I think I was
like let's take the bus
let's train no that was like how the
hell are we I was like oh no a VBAC XL
yeah so we got we got into the car and
we thought we have to keep it from the
uber driver and I remember we'll just
like a looking at each other we was sort
of still in character he was like so
where are you guys going and why the
makalah and he was like oh I kind of
asking us questions and one more like
our characters kind of like
disintegrated it just be something we're
like here's what's actually going on
we're sneaking into the Met Gala and
you're driving us there I think he was a
youtuber or something yeah me apparently
had like 1 million subscribers it was
fate for us to get him as a driver
we're approaching the Met Gala and we
see some police so I decided to stop the
car and we roll down the window and I
just asked the police where's the
entrance to the Met Gala and they were
like great this way
we hold around the corner was the line
of huge black cars filled with
celebrities and I think that's when it
really hit me was like people everywhere
people have cameras people were touching
out windows like taking photos of us
like banging on the glass yeah I
remember I was shaking I felt a rush of
adrenaline we didn't say a word to each
other we were just like oh my god you're
about to walk in you kind of felt like
everything was in slow motion
it was emotion in that moment I didn't
feel like I was pretending to be a
celebrity I felt like I was a celebrity
I remember pulling up and seeing like
the entrance of the red carpet and
there's a huge security guys like
opening the doors closing the door feels
like these hot male got a male models
whoever opened up my door was cute lucky
there's a huge SUV in front of us and
they open the door and it was Nicki
Minaj so she gets out with her entourage
and I'm like I don't know even know if I
said anything but I like might have
nudged you and it was like and we were
like miming to each other and then you
notice Madonna Madonna was behind us yes
you had cameras and you were kind of
trying to like push them aside because
we realized we couldn't really be press
anymore press doesn't just roll up onto
the red carpet ready to be photographed
you were squeezed my hands so tightly
there's just this big crowd of
celebrities we kind of just like pulled
over behind them to try and blend in and
like regroup and turns out we were next
to is that we crop it it's like right
next to zoe kravitz and Lord miles
teller and I may have had a few little
eyes together I think they locked we
noticed that there was a small little
kind of makeshift table with this girl
behind it with a checklist we tried to
avoid that and I remember she gave us
some eyes I was like ooh is she gonna
come over here or do we need a check-in
but I remember as we were like trying to
snake our way kind of into the the crowd
we realized we were gonna be spit
onto the red carpet they just would have
been amazing amazing but terrible so we
kind of are panicking and like we can't
turn back we can't go out there what do
we do so we kind of just are standing
there like non-verbally communicating
with our eyes mhmmm and freaking out
eventually the lady came up to us I
don't know I just got my together I
really calmed down and I said that we
were from that big magazine that we
planned
I didn't say a name so she went back to
look and she was like this is not the
press entrance and I was like she's on
to us like there's no way I might as
well just like beat them to it so I kind
of like scram yeah I just started
running before I even noticed I remember
I looked around like sprinting we try
and go to the press entrance so pretty
much the guy said no but then we asked
to use the bathroom we were we would
determined on our way to the bathroom we
met this guy we start speaking
he was somebody stylist I think Oh a saw
you guys inside like what happened
they're like oh oh there was a mixup
like we were trying to get there for
press but we got there too late like now
we're just trying to figure out like how
to get in we're still in character a
little bit and then we exchanged numbers
we we went to the bathroom kind of
realized like it wasn't gonna work so we
we went out we lost him yeah we lost
hope
we took an uber black on the way there
and then we took I think an uber pool on
the way back cuz we were like you know
we are humble girls on a budget and we
were both kind of just like freaking out
over what just happened
just like recapping it pretty sure you
did uber driver or whoever was in the
car was like did I just hear you guys
correctly like yeah we did what we
thought was just this guy like trying to
hit on us he was like texting us to come
out and like come to this party with him
and we're like oh we're tired we don't
really know this guy's deal whatever it
actually turned out that it was the
official after-party for the Met Gala
and there were even more celebs at the
after-party then the neck outlaw and we
didn't go and we should have for anyone
who says we didn't actually get into the
Met Gala we did we were sandwiched in
between a Nicki Minaj miles teller Bella
Hadid Madonna Victoria Secret models
goodbye that no
[Music]